so uh welcome to uh today's meeting of
the cabinet both those that are
participating and those who are watching
on the live stream
if members have technical difficulties
during the meeting then please contact
the democratic services officer on call
who will attempt to assist you
on call today is mr hughes and his
number is 577208
it will also be at the top of the chat
thread for members if you need it
for those of you watching by the
council's youtube stream
please follow the instructions below the
video if there are any issues with the
live feed
i would ask participants when you're not
speaking please mute your mic
watching by the council's youtube stream
please follow the instructions below the
video if there are any issues with the
live feed i would ask participants when
you're not speaking please mute your
microphone
this minimizes background noise and will
help everyone in listening to the
proceedings
microphones must only be on if the
participant has been granted permission
to speak
to gain my permission to speak please
very briefly indicate on the chat to the
right side of the screen
and i will then make a note and go back
to you once the person speaking is
finished
please note that we'll be following the
usual cabinet protocols in which
other members of the council usually
only speak once on each item
would everyone present please ensure
that their mobile phones are turned to
silent
and they're not used to make or receive
phone calls while the meeting's in
progress
please also refrain from checking emails
or conducting other business
and ensure that you're in a quiet room
free from distractions for the duration
of the meeting
please note that this meeting is being
live streamed for members of the public
the meeting will also be recorded and
subsequently broadcast on the internet
so first of all can i ask members of the
cabinet um to
confirm that they are present when i
read out their name
um i'll ask for 20.1 uh members
separately um but first of all let's do
members of the cabinet and i do have
apologies this evening
from both councillor whitehead and
councillor alban
so councillor duckworth can you confirm
you're here
here thank you and councillor yates
i'm here thank you now before i come to
uh item 20.1 i have to announce i'm
afraid that item four
has been withdrawn or i am withdrawing
it
and the reason for that is that uh it's
been pointed out to me this morning
quite helpfully
by a member of the public um that the uh
one of the documents
circulated with item four is not uh
the appropriate document to go with the
pool version of that document
and i think in the issue in the interest
of transparency
we ought to be circulating the correct
document with the report so that
everybody can consider it
um and we can have a proper discussion
on that basis i wasn't keen that we
circulated the correct version tonight
when the public haven't had an
opportunity to see it
so my intention is that we'll bring that
item back to the august meeting and i do
apologize to
members and to members of the public who
may have joined the stream in order to
see what we had to say about that item
but we won't be considering it tonight
so i did have a number of members who
wanted to speak on item for but
obviously there's nothing to speak about
does anybody wish to speak on any other
item this evening
doesn't appear so okay
so i've already dealt with apologies um
does anybody ever declare any
declarations of interest for any item of
business on the agenda this evening
no time to take that as read minutes of
the previous meeting to approve the
summary and recommendations and
decisions of the cabinet meeting held on
the 18th of june
copy of which is attached to the agenda
pack um i will propose the minutes to
have a seconder
i'll second that that's the duck with
second in it
uh unless i hear any objection i'll take
those as approved
and i'm not hearing any objections so we
skip over item four we go on to item
five as councillor whitehead is not
available this evening i shall be
introducing this item
the report seeks authority for the
council to enter into two new contracts
for works to its housing stock
the works include a five-year term
contract for the completion of external
cyclical decorations is required
and the full refurbishment of passenger
lifts in seven
council-owned residential blocks the
external decorations contract
will enable the delivery of a five-year
program of repair and decoration
the works will include both cyclical
external decorations to council owned
residential properties
and to the internal common part of
blocks of flats the works planned for
the coming five years have been valued
at 1 million
and 1 million and twenty eight thousand
eight hundred and ninety five pounds
funding for this program is included
within the council's approved
medium-term
hra revenue budget the lift program will
provide for the full refurbishment of
the lifts
listed in the pro in the report ensuring
that they have a further 25 years of
life the funding to complete the program
estimated that 1.6 million
is included within the hra budget report
also on the agenda for this meeting
which is due to be considered full
council on the 10th of september
for decision so i move the
recommendations and i'll just read those
out for
clarity the letting of the contract for
the refurbishment has seven passenger
lifts as detailed in the report
and the letting of a term contract for
the completion of a program of external
cyclical declarations
as detailed in the report is there a
secondary
i'll second that that's seconded by
councillor duckworth
um i don't know mr paul so there's
anything that you'd like to say on this
item as we don't have any other speakers
um well i think you've you've covered
all the key issues
um in in the um in the introduction
i think probably the key thing the
reason why we're seeing this report now
we haven't seen
reports like this previously uh is the
result of clarification about
um the value of key decisions so key
decisions
effectively contracts over quarter
million that now
um have to come to cabinet for decision
and so this report actually is going to
be the first of a series of reports
about new the letting of new contracts
in relation to housing
okay thanks very much any discussion
members
okay thanks very much so is that agreed
agreed agreed okay so we move on to item
six which is the budget monitoring
report
council yates thank you
in the general funds budget 2019 to 2020
thanos council overspent by around 500
000 pounds in order to set the budget
for 2020 to 21 which is this year's
budget we had to find savings of around
730 000 pounds
many of the planned savings we put into
the budget in february are now unlikely
to be delivered
due to covert on top of this the
pandemic has added to our costs and
negatively affected our income
generation
our current estimates suggest the total
shortfall from lost income
and additional gender and additional
expenditure of 5.6 million pounds
we have estimated government grants of
2.6 million
this leaves a budget gap of 3 million
pounds
any longer-term financial impact of
coronavirus will be picked up in the 20
to 1
to 22 budget next year's budget will
also have to address the underlying
budget problem
of undelivered savings even if our
income bounces back
today cabinet is proposing action to
address the current year gap
cabinet does not want to cut services or
make redundancies
so the proposals provide funding for the
3 million pounds from reserves
the council already had low reserves
before coronavirus
so there were difficult choices to be
made as to which reserves to use
cabinet proposals are set out in annex
1. these are proposals to council
so the final decision will be made by
council
in the meantime members will continue to
be kept informed by officers explaining
the figures and also updating on any
changes
there are a lot of moving parts and is
almost certain that the figures will
change over the coming weeks and months
including possibility that they will
change by the full council
in 10th of september in the 10th of
september
by making a decision now the cabinet is
showing that it wishes to address the
budget problems head-on
this gives reassurance to the section
151 officer that the council will take
decisions to address the covert losses
we propose doing this by allocating some
of these losses to specific reserves
some 2.2 million pounds of them
the remaining 800 thousand pounds will
be held in the covid shortfall reserve
and only allocated service budgets as
and when is needed
this helps manage the uncertainty in our
estimates
some estimates on income loss for
example may turn out to be not as bad as
we think
so not all the shortfall reserve may be
called upon if this happens depending on
the size of any balance at the end of
the year we may need to make a decision
as to whether or not to obtain the
reserve
we do not know what the long-term impact
of covert will be on the council's
finances
i know you may well have to make further
tough decisions in the weeks and months
to follow
none of these choices are easy i hope
the council can agree on this list
of reserves in order to protect jobs and
frontline services
if cabinet approves support it will form
the recommendations to council
because of the size of budget movements
only council can approve them
i therefore move the recommendations
thank you councillor yates um i think
i'd like to underline
um my own feelings about the uncertainty
of the position
it's absolutely right that we bring
forward a report which estimates what we
think the position is and
you know i pay tribute to the finance
staff um mr willis and mr blandell for
the work that's gone into this report
because i know that um
i know a lot of work's gone into it and
also there have been some difficult
decisions that senior officers have had
to consider here
and bring to cabinet and which we've had
to look at
so we're very much subject to
external factors in this report i think
if we were suddenly making a
withdrawal of three million pounds from
our reserves for something that the
council had done
then i think the the members would be
right to be alarmed
um i think that we are dealing with a
situation which is completely
unprecedented
and we don't know how it's going to
unfold and we're doing our best to
make preparations around that and make
the decisions
um to protect the council's position and
most of all to protect the services of
our residents
and the jobs of our staff because we
mustn't forget them either
um so i'm happy to support this um and
this is any further comment
right uh actually i think i need to
second it not quite sure whether i said
that but i am second again
um okay we agreed members agreed
thank you uh and i can agree item seven
um
which is the revised hra budget
monitoring 2021
and the hra provisional out turn 2019 20
is council yates
thank you the housing revenue account is
having to cope with the same uncertainty
as the general fund
the main potential impact of covert is
on housing rent income collection
this may yet be insulated from some of
the worst effects of covid
as about two-thirds of our rent income
is from benefits however there will be
an impact
perhaps a bigger challenge to the hra
now and over the longer term
is in accommodating the transfer of east
kent housing to the council
i believe there is agreement across the
council that this is the right thing to
do
and cabinet has agreed that the date of
transfer will be the first of october
but there are many costs of doing this
taken together with the covert estimated
costs
their age the hra has a budget gap of
1.4 million pounds
there are substantial one-off costs
relating to project management and i.t
there are also costs associated with
fixing the problems we're inheriting
with east kent housing many of the
reasons for the decision to bring it
in-house were related to tenant health
and safety concerns around issues such
as fire safety
and gas safety our tower blocks require
a huge amount of investment
coupled with the cost of creating the
new tenant and leaseholder service
the hra's finances are taking a large
hit
this report shows that over the long
term the hra can recover
although some of the warnings regarding
uncertainty that affect the general fund
also affects the hra i'll move the
recommendations
thank you council yates i'll second that
any further discussion members
no should we take that as agreed agreed
agreed thank you okay
so that concludes the business for
tonight's meeting so i declare the
meeting closed at
1743 thank you to everyone who
participated into those watching from
home
and the live streaming streaming of the
meeting will now end thank you